[Music]
[Applause]
michael gorbachev came to power at a
time when the ussr was seen as the evil
empire locked in a nuclear arms race
with the united states
under his leadership the cold war would
finally come to an end but the soviet
union would collapse
he stopped a cold war
he stopped confrontation between east
and west
millions hundreds of millions of people
in the world
uh must
say thank you mr gorbachev for freedom
for independence for new policy for
democracy for for liberal political
systems
after the death of constantine chernenka
gorbachev was seen as a new kind of
soviet leader
relatively young and a man who was able
to engage easily with the people
charm them in a way his aged
predecessors had not
[Applause]
a man western leaders could do business
with
[Music]
but gorbachev inherited a superpower
with a failing economy
long queues outside empty shops
punctuated daily life
[Music]
gorbachev knew the soviet union could no
longer afford the cold war
in the white house he found a president
equally interested in reducing nuclear
weapons
[Music]
their signature agreement to ban short
and medium-range ballistic missiles
halting the nuclear arms race
the importance of this treaty transcends
numbers
we have listened to the wisdom of in an
old russian maxim
and i'm sure
you're familiar with it
my semester general secretary though my
pronunciation may give you difficulty
the maxim is dovahyai no proverai
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
the lowest point of his leadership was
the chernobyl nuclear disaster
it took gorbachev three weeks to speak
publicly about what had happened
but he was determined that the failings
chernobyl uncovered would only
accelerate the pace of his reforms
he introduced glasnost openness
[Music]
rock bands previously underground were
performing on stage
victor tsoy's peremene summed up the
mood of the time
our hearts demand change the cory said
[Music]
gorbachev withdrew the troops from
afghanistan
[Applause]
as the berlin wall came down he refused
to intervene even as the communist
regimes of eastern europe collapsed
he was awarded the nobel peace prize the
following year
but not everyone was celebrating
on one hand
that was the end
of the
cold war
a symbol a symbol of the end of the cold
war
on the other hand
we realized
that what will go after that
will be very very difficult and
dangerous
in august 1991 tanks rolled into red
square
as conservative hardliners attempted a
coup d'etat
[Music]
was kept under house arrest in crimea
but this time the people pushed back
[Music]
boris yeltsin rallied the crowds outside
the white house
[Applause]
unarmed civilians face down tanks
six years under gorbachev had given them
courage and something worth fighting for
he gave us this feeling of safety
and this feeling of freedom
and this feeling of freedom of speech
six years of freedom
and and suddenly
some very strange guys in if and kgb
said us oh no now it's again
totalitarian muslim no people said no we
don't want more and people
came to the streets
after three days the coup collapsed and
gorbachev returned with his family to
moscow
[Applause]
but the balance of power had shifted
away from him and he was losing ground
politically
[Applause]
in november yeltsin banned the communist
party from russia
on christmas day 1991 gorbachev had no
choice but to resign
his final order was the lowering of the
red flag over the kremlin the soviet
union was no more
many felt let down
as a diplomat especially
who
called
to protect and project the interest of
the country it is much
much much more easier
to
protect the and project the interests of
a superpower
then in comparison with
what
has left of the super power
through it all by his side was raisa the
love of his life and his closest counsel
the couple met at university in moscow
they were married for 46 years
when she died from leukemia in 1999 he
was inconsolable
when she died my life was taken away
from me he said later
for me and for my mother as well he was
he was an example you know of of a
perfect husband of a perfect man
for every woman
and
when since i was
a little kid
i saw how
their relationships was my grandmother
and how he loved her
and so on and
it was very difficult to find somebody
somebody else like this
he remained critical of his successes in
the kremlin and especially of vladimir
putin a man whose long decades in power
saw the freedoms which gorbachev had won
for his people crushed
[Music]
celebrated abroad his legacy at home was
conflicted many blaming him for the
chaos which followed the soviet union's
collapse
but he was admired too
for allowing for the promise of
democracy and freedom even if it remains
unfulfilled do you recognize president
reagan
living into his 90s and through the
global pandemic mikhail gorbachev would
quote the phrase his father had told him
on his return from world war ii we
fought until we ran out of fight he said
that's how you must live
diana magnay sky news moscow